[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le collège du chaudron et les visuels
voilà la nouvelle dénomination de cet
établissement départemental
la conseillère départementale jeune et
enthousiaste recevoir un ministre de
l'éducation nationale dans son collège
est une première quelques questions en
vies humaines
[Musique]
avec les rentrées scolaires de france au
chaudron c'est qu'en musique que
l'établissement de ses portes
une nouveauté qui ravit le chef
d'établissement c'est une excellente
rentrée d'autant plus que c'est vraiment
une manière d'accueillir dans la plus
digne alité dans la joie les élèves
d'une manière en tout cas de l'été ce
traité perdre une école de la
citoyenneté est une école l'a hébergé
une école de mémoire pour que les choses
ne se reproduisent plus c'est pour cela
dans le même sillage il râle livre on
doit vous éclairez nous les avons posées
il donné mardi des nières si bien aux
personnages de l'histoire qui donna son
nom à cet établissement construit sur
les cendres du modding collège du se
trouve à portée de nom d'un homme qui
ont le nom peut paraître lointain aux
réunionnais d oise elle mais qui a été
un grand homme pour l'humanité toute
entière on l'appelait le dernier des
justes lui même enseignant il nous a
piqué il n'y a pas si longtemps il ya
quelques mois l'année dernière
et c'est vrai qu'il a portée des valeurs
de justice de paix mais aussi de pardon
alors faire porter un collège
le lieu qui accueille des jeunes ces
valeurs là ne semblait être importants
mais bienvenu levier n'est possible
d'allonger même que le mât pour demain
sur l'idole des jeunes collégiens en
tirez-vous de ce grand homme prendra
voulait devenir d'un que les utiliser
pour apprendre à cliquer la lune le
collège de la république est aussi celui
de la citoyenneté
l'histoire montre ainsi que de la
violence peut naître lieu de prospérité
pour notre jeunesse exemple de l'elysée
l'exemple de la résilience c'est un
exemple d'une une capacité à ne jamais
perdre espoir
et puis c'est un exemple d'une capacité
à construire compris à partir d'une
expérience donc une négative qui soit et
il est très bon que nos élèves
apprennent vite tout simplement parce
qu'il ya eu des bonnes et des mauvaises
choses ne pourra toujours aller de
l'avant toujours se projeter dans le
futur dans un esprit positif et
d'industrie de transmission des valeurs
et des connaissances
la rencontre avec la communauté
éducative caucus est rentré plein
d'espoir d'abord avec des jeunes c'est
toujours plein d'espoir et
d'enthousiasmé donc face à ces frites
olivia est pris en présence du ministre
de l'éducation qui vient à la réunion
c'est à la rentrée avec nos élèves et en
chansons je pense que c'est une journée
formidable
[Musique]